[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL AMES: Your
genome is probably
the single most identifying
unique thing about you.
The goal of
personalized medicine
is about gathering as much data
as we can on people to help
us understand them better.
KRISTY CROOKS: In the research
study through the Colorado
Center for
Personalized Medicine,
we're trying to leverage those
differences in our discoveries.
For each patient who
undergoes genotyping,
we get about 2.1 million
pieces of genetic data.
MICHAEL AMES: What we need is
the computational resources
to make sure that we will
never run out of storage space
or that we will never
pay for storage space
that we're not using.
Underlying all of
those challenges
are the questions of security.
KRISTY CROOKS: It needs
to be stored somewhere
that is HIPAA compliant,
even if it's de-identified.
MICHAEL AMES: And
our solution was
to move that data onto
Google Cloud Platform.
It gave us a way that was cost
effective and highly scalable.
And if that was all
it had given us,
we would have been
perfectly pleased.
What we're finding is
that that partnership
is enabling us to drive to
the next level of innovation
and advanced analytics.
Google BigQuery as
a data warehouse,
that's our beating heart.
We gather data from lots
of different places.
We have to match
up patient records.
That activity took about
eight hours to run.
We re-implemented that
logic in Google BigQuery,
and it finishes now
in about 15 minutes.
Through personalized
medicine, we
can give doctors tools to
make the best diagnoses
and treatment decisions.
With Google Cloud Platform,
we are chasing down
every opportunity to
improve human health
by bringing this data
together and analyzing it
in ways that have never
been analyzed before.